when you start to think about
cryptocurrencies bitcoin specifically uh
as i mentioned at the intro
you all have been paying attention to
this since about 2015 in terms of
research in 2017 you started to actually
get into the mining business and from
there i've expanded a lot of what you're
doing in the space maybe give us a quick
overview like what is the thesis why are
you all uh who you know frankly are just
arbitraging you really long time
horizons and and tend to be very uh kind
of research driven investors why are you
so interested in bitcoin
cryptocurrencies
well you know when i first heard the
story uh it immediately
hit home with me based on supply and
demand basic economics right there's a
limited supply there's growing demand
correcting mechanism is the price so i
can see how you can make a lot of money
of it but the thing that i mentioned
starting off the crisis in confidence uh
is the crisis incompetence and our
financial leaders our legal leaders our
medical leaders etc
so bitcoin takes away
uh the ability to print money and to
steal time from you and it puts it into
the hands of basically math or an
algorithm and
that's a very powerful tool and for the
bulk of history human history most of
the time money has actually been in the
hand private hands not in government's
hands and the governments around the
world have abused that power and i think
people are going to want to take that
back and i see bitcoin potentially
playing a massive role in that so
there's a possibility i don't know how
it's going to play out that bitcoin
becomes a reserve currency uh
status
and the world actually puts itself on
that standard
and if that happens
you know everyone's going to want to own
that i think you're starting to see that
play out and and it's almost impossible
to keep out keep up with the
progress that's being made literally on
a daily basis within the bitcoin
community and things that are going
there and you know that probably better
than anyone when you think about uh
bitcoin's future uh i always say that
like it's pretty obvious it's a great
store of value over long periods of time
right but one of the best performing if
not the best performing asset over the
last decade compounding at 150 annually
uh during that time period
uh and still you know relatively small
percentage of the global population has
any right on the grand scheme of things
and and so fix up asset if that demand
continues to uh uh to become pervasive
then obviously the price will go up uh
what do you think is uh kind of likely
to occur do you think that bitcoin could
rise to be the global reserve currency
do you think it becomes uh just another
asset that central banks put into their
reserves like what do you think is like
the likely outcome here
i i think i think the established
powers are going to fight it for time i
think it's but it's inevitable um and i
think they're going to get on board with
that so my own assessment is that you
know most people are viewing bitcoin is
still a curiosity i'm viewing it more as
a necessity to fix a lot of the problems
in the world so my assessment is that a
single bitcoin is ultimately going to go
into the many millions of dollars um how
it gets from point a to point b nobody
knows you know
really most
not most every currency has collapsed
relative to bitcoin as you pointed out
and i think that it's going to continue
because i don't see how
they get out of this dead burden without
continuing to print and to inflate and i
think more and more people are going to
recognize that as a store of value and
potentially reserve
the world's reserve currency so
i'm pretty optimistic about it and again
you don't need a big amount of
exposure to this if in that success mode
you'll you'll do incredibly well and
you'll you'll be able to outrun the
inflation that i think likely is is
going to occur hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time